la nature qui évolue au fil des saisons
des époques
christine besson semble inspirer la
transcrit sur ses toiles en venant tout
à l'heure sur l'autoroute
j'étais à l'arrêt et j'ai vu les
à cassis en ce moment qui change de
couleur et y avait un camaïeu de vert
bleu et ça tout de suite ça attire mon
attention la nature m'apporte beaucoup
l'artiste parisienne travaille par
séville elle peint jusqu'à 40 toiles par
an christine besson varie les techniques
en travaillant beaucoup avec du papier
une texture particulière pour emmener le
public dans un univers ma peinture j'ai
pas trop envie que ce soit conceptuel
j'ai envie que les gens rentrent dans ma
peinture
ma peinture c'est mes émotions mais j'ai
envie que les gens écrivent une histoire
cette série gelé
et appeler passe muraille pour que les
gens juste justement trouve une petite
faille dans mes tableaux une nature un
vivant qui inspire aussi serge guarnieri
une inspiration de l'infiniment petit et
de l'infiniment grand
ça peut être
minéral végétal animal mais l'impulsion
c'était un embryon à bourgeon le big
bang
le microcosme tout ce qui est
bactériologique le tout début que
l'impulsion de la vie c'est à dire le
mot c'est pour ça que je me suis aussi
beaucoup de l'eau ce lot est venu enfin
la vie est venue de l'autre tout ce qui
est fonds marins
les habits sont en général serge garnier
imagine ainsi des vies primaire
l'artiste sculpte des matières
exigeantes comme le fer à béton
ces oeuvres recréer le mouvement des
êtres vivants je me suis toujours
intéressé à la nature depuis tout petit
en fin de compte rien qu'à une petite
pierre m'inspirait enfin j'observais
énormément et c'est la nature qui va un
qui m'a conduit à ça en fin de compte a
cherché à imaginer à comprendre leurs
oeuvres se répondent et s'interpellent
christine besson et serge guarnieri
expose jusqu'au 14 janvier